liberal Democrat Senator John fedman has
just lambasted the government of South
Africa for encouraging and perpetrating
genocide against white people wait what
and now let's also talk about that now
we're talking about genocide and now
South Africa now is now bringing that
kind of a a trial maybe South Africa
maybe ought to sit this one out when
they're talking about
criticizing let me read that
again liberal Democrat Senator
lambasted South Africa for genocide
against white people which is a fact by
the way here's the leader of the third
largest political party in the South
African
Parliament kiss the the
fmer kiss the the
[Applause]
fmer
ATT shoot to kill kill the Boer kill the
farmer now Federman made those comments
in order to make a different point in
support of Israel's actions against Gaza
so it wasn't totally out of the blue but
still fetterman's comments seem to
suggest that we are now officially
living in a9s comedy movie in which the
protagonist gets hit on the head and
suddenly changes all his views about
everything marvelous news for two
reasons one Senator Federman is clearly
making great strides in recovering from
his health issues and two because as
fetterman's brain function improves he
is becoming increasingly right-wing I'm
Michael NES this is the Michael N
[Music]
show
Lil NZ X the rapper who infamously made
a music video depicting him himself
getting sodomized by the devil uh
announces that he's about to become a
Christian and I'm a little skeptical but
we'll we'll get to that in one second
first though I guess it's sort of a
related story uh This Out of Africa wow
talk about all sorts of tie-ins tie-ins
to the Federman opening tie-ins to
little nasx
uh there were widespread news reports
based on a document that came out of the
Holy Office of the Vatican that said
that the Vatican was now going to
permit blessings for same-sex couples
now many people pointed to the document
that came out of the Holy office and
said no it doesn't actually permit
blessings of same-sex unions it doesn't
actually change Church teaching on
marriage and the relation of men to
women it does no it's it's much more
modest than that nothing changed at all
but the the document has led to
widespread confusion very prominent
liberal priests have interpreted the
document quite publicly as affirming
blessings for these same-sex couples and
the the Vatican hasn't really said too
much about it uh now you have Bishops
Out of Africa responding to the Vatican
saying that as they read this document
it's all a little bit confusing but in
any case they are not going to be
blessing same-sex unions they're not
going to be uh causing that kind of
Scandal uh led by Cardinal ambongo uh
they say that they will there will be
quote no blessing for homosexual couples
in Africa as such unions are contrary to
the will of God and as homosexual acts
are intrinsically disordered and
contrary to the natural law it could all
be summed up by the py line of this
African spokesman why are you
gay who says I'm
gay you are
gay you know that seems like a joke and
I don't you know I don't think that that
gentleman works for the Cardinals or the
Bishops or anything but he is actually a
a devout Catholic apparently that guy
the guy from the why are you gay you are
gay me is Simon kagua Nala is Ugandan
and he's a devoted Catholic and so why
do I bring up this story there's there's
enough weird sex stuff in the news that
we don't need to point to another
example of it the reason I bring this up
is to talk about Africa actually and the
difference between Africa and the West
as seen from the Vantage of the Catholic
Church which is Catholic so it spans the
whole
world liberalism is a western
thing
liberalism is a western thing that
sprouted up out of Europe's rejection of
the faith that formed her whole
civilization in in America we talk about
liberalism and leftism as though this
were the natural ideology of all the
marginalized and oppressed peoples
especially the peoples of color all of
the people on the fringes against the
evil white man but it's it's really not
it's really not Africa is not a liberal
Place far from it the African Bishops
the African Cardinals the they're not
the liberal ones in the church okay
liberalism is an ideology that is
imposed On The World by
Europeans and specifically by Europeans
who have rejected their ancestral Faith
this is why liberalism is just a kind of
a parody of
Christianity it
it has similar impulses to Christianity
it uses similar kind of language as
Christianity the language of Rights the
language of dignity the the language of
um equality the language of Freedom true
freedom but it it takes God out of the
equation and so everything gets
extremely perverted and everything falls
to PO this has been a problem not just
for the last 50 60 years in the west
this has been a problem for the last 500
years in the west okay this is a problem
of modernity especially gaining esteem
during the Enlightenment project which
is shoot we've got this great
civilization but we've lost our
faith what are we going to do now okay I
know what we'll do we'll get rid of God
and then we'll be gods and we'll we'll
discover all the secrets of the universe
and we'll we'll be the masters of our
own fate and we yeah we okay we don't
think that God created morality or
something but it doesn't matter we don't
need God for Morality we'll just kind of
do it ourselves all right and we can
Tinker around and we can improve on
things actually and it hasn't worked it
hasn't worked at all
by virtually every measure our
civilization has crumbled since we've
tried to do that most notably in the
fact that we don't form families and
have children anymore so the Civil
civilization is literally dying and and
it seems
like we we can't even imagine that other
people would reject that
idea liberals in the west are shocked
when African bishops come out and they
say yeah we're going to stick with the
2,000-year teaching of the church we're
not going to I'm not saying we're not
rejecting anything out of the Vatican
we're just if there is any confusion
we're going to we're going to clarify
our view of things which is we stick
with the 2,000 year teaching of the
church and we're not going to lead
people into Scandal maybe maybe the West
could take a a note from these African
Cardinals and return to her very finest
traditions this brings me back to a
story in the states story is that a
female teacher has been charged with
sleeping with a 16-year-old male student
the teacher is rather young herself
she's 26 years old and she's pretty
good-look and
so do we we I we have I guess we have to
there's only there's only one response
ever to the where were these teachers
when I was in school right that's the
that's the response that's a response un
universally one of these stories crops
up every month I don't know probably
more than that and it's some hot young
teacher and some teenage boy usually a
little bit of an older teenage 16 17 and
and they sleep together and the story
comes out and she gets charged with
sexual assault and then every person in
the country at least every guy says hey
nice cool man where were these teachers
when I was in school and it's kind of a
funny line I'm not denying that it's a
funny line but the fact that that's
always the
response tells you something about our
sexual ethic cuz it's it's legitimately
very bad it's sincerely a bad thing and
it's not not just bad because
16-year-old boys shouldn't be having sex
they shouldn't be a lot of them do but
they shouldn't
be it's not just bad because this woman
is in a position of power and so there's
a a big Power imbalance here it's not
just bad because parents should be able
to send their kids to school without
worrying about their their kids being
molested by
teachers it's not it's not just bad
because that woman is divorced so it
creates all sorts of plants all new
seeds of of
Scandal in kids Minds about that about
what marriage is about what sex is it's
not just bad because he could have
gotten her pregnant and then what would
that have led to I don't know would that
have led to an abortion I certainly hope
not would that could have derailed a lot
of this kid's life
what it's it's bad
because since the 1960s We have replaced
our old moral order with one moral Maxim
and that is if it feels good do it if it
feels good then you should do
it now if if that's our moral maximum
why should this kid not be allowed to
sleep with his teacher especially if
she's kind of young and hot and willing
well you might say because he's a minor
he's 16 oh he's 16 and he shouldn't be
allowed to have a consensual sexual
relationship with his teacher well of
course he can't have a consensual sexual
relationship a 16-year-old can't consent
oh interesting cuz I was told that an
8-year-old can consent to sexual mutil
ations and and puberty blockers and
hormones that will forever change his
biochemistry and weaken his bones and
sterilize him or her and probably lead
to early death so hold on an 8-year-old
can consent to that kind of permanent
radical
sexual action but a 16-year-old can't
have a fling with his young
teacher no of course that that breaks
down
too can even the the
basic moral Criterion that we accept in
Liberal modernity consent starts to
break down well no maybe look an
8-year-old can consent to that just not
this and 16-year-old can consent to that
just not this it starts to break down we
all know that this story is wrong most
most sensible people know that this
story is wrong it's it's just so
scandalous it leads to a stumbling block
this is what the millstone verse of the
Bible is about whoever causes one of
these little ones to stumble mil the fa
famous Millstone verse it's it's not
about physically ing children it's about
creating Scandal and leading people away
from
God if we all know that there's
something a little bit wrong with
this the weirdest part of the story is
that apparently the kid's father knew
and the kid's father allowed it to
happen so then the joke is oh wow father
of the year I'm going to give him number
number one dad in town mug for for
Father's day but he's not the father of
the year that's actually very bad it's
very bad to do and and we all kind of
know it deep down so what that implies
then is that
our moral revolution of the last 60
years is wrong what that implies then is
there are other moral criteria to judge
to stop making the same old joke about
this
story forces us to reconsider the entire
moral Revolution that we've had since
the 1960s
frankly this the seeds of a moral
Revolution that go back much much
further than that are
we able to to return to that are we
living in a world after virtue where we
we just can't make sense of that more
are is there a chance that we can
recover something of uh a sensible ethic
remains to be seen we got to talk about
it and when you want to talk you got to
check out P talk right now go to Pur
talk.com if you are looking to save
money this year but don't want to
sacrifice your Sal service Pure Talk has
your back instead of paying your current
cell phone provider 60 70 80 bucks a
line Pure Talk has unlimited plans
starting at just 20 bucks a month you
will get the same coverage that you're
used to on America's Most Dependable 5G
Network for just 20 bucks bucks a month
this is how the average family saves
almost $1,000 a year switch to a
wireless company that shares your
beliefs a company that is veteran-owned
that serves veterans and that isn't
afraid to invest in shows like mine
these guys are on the best network in
the country it is available for
international so that was for a while
people said well if I have pure talk and
I I travel overseas or something and M
they now have international it's just
amazing you're if you're not switching
to p TR you were just throwing money out
the window and you can switch in as
little as 10 minutes go to Pur
talk.com right now you'll save an
additional 50% off your first month that
is p talk.com kwes Pur talk.com start
the year saving on wireless with a
company you can be proud of the most
dist most disturbing story that I've
read in probably a year just came out
and it is gone viral even though it's a
local news story here it is from the
local Fox affiliate in Houston two
toddlers were allegedly sexually
assaulted in a bathroom at the Galleria
by multiple men one of the men was a
mall employee the FBI has arrested
Arthur Hector Fernandez III in charge
the 29-year-old with sexual exploitation
of children Fernandez is pictured here
on his private Instagram with the
username allegedly Hector his account
was named in court documents that
detailed the disturbing allegations that
he and at least six other unidentified
men sexually assaulted and raped a
toddler at what appeared to be a
Galleria Mall bathroom court documents
say last month the Australian Center to
counter child exploitation reported four
explicit videos found on the dark web to
the FBI in which at least two toddlers
ages 2 and three were filmed being
sexually and verbally assaulted by
multiple men at once relatives of the
toddlers told investigators Fernandez
was a friend and fellow Galleria
employee who offered to watch the kids
while they were at work at the
mall see it's right there on the
internet chilling my home is Houston
rainbow flag rainbow flag he looks he
looks so happy doesn't he and he commits
as heinous a crime as anyone could
possibly imagine a lot of people are
calling for the death penalty as a
matter of Justice I think it would be
perfectly right to execute all of these
men very swiftly um my only hold up on
the death penalty for rapists of any
sort even including the most egregious
rapists is it has nothing to do with
them or their right to not be executed
it it only has to do with a credential
question
of if you kill rapists if the if the P
punishment for rape is the death penalty
then there's no incentive for the
rapists not to kill their victims so
that's my only credential uh hold up
against it but you know if if these guys
all hanged after being convicted I would
you know not lose one second sleep about
it in fact if that would feel quite good
and and would seem quite just the part
of this story that no one's talking
about is the internet part of
it everyone's talking about the action
because that's that's the the heart of
the evil here but the more politically
significant part I think is how these
guys were
apprehended they put they they filmed
pornography and then put it on the
internet this guy was a big user of the
internet had a big public profile and he
he in fact talked about his sexual
exploits in the profile implicitly
that's what the rainbow is about he's
not using that rainbow as a symbol that
God gives to man to say that he'll never
flood destroy the world again in a flood
right that's a symbol of a very
particular and deviant sexual identity
and even if one has deviant sexual
desires or sexual behaviors or whatever
that's one matter to to make that your
identity to put that in your bio on a
social media account that's a big red
flag being chronically online that's
kind of a big red flag and then these
guys like a lot of people were obviously
completely addicted to pornography so it
raises a question
if internet pornography were not so
normalized would these guys have
committed this action
maybe they would have they're obviously
perverts but they didn't they didn't
just go rape a
child they filmed it they were producing
pornography for other perverts because
there is a medium through which they can
send this pornography to other perverts
would would they have done that if
pornography were not so normalized so
difficult to prosecute declared a a a a
matter of free speech by some extreme
liberals in recent decades I don't know
maybe but would would the instances of
this kind of child
exploitation really uh be quite so so
widespread I'm not
sure we all have we have to when I
report on this I have to say that these
men allegedly raped the
toddler even though there's video
footage of the the men were apprehended
because there's video footage but we
still have to say allegedly well when
there's a a video it makes that word
seem kind of ridiculous doesn't
it this isn't even just the the far
reaches of the dark hidden internet
where you've got to you know have five
separate handshakes to to log into it
there was a major child sexual
exploitation problem on the biggest porn
sites in the country we covered it just
a few weeks ago on PornHub and the the
Affiliated websites which constitute the
largest purveyors of pornography on the
internet if
the only moral Maxim that we have is if
it feels good to it and you know a
corollary to that is as long as
everything's
consensual it's not going to be long
before you get to these kinds of crimes
because people are going to chip away at
consent you're already seeing that
happen with the oh an 8-year-old can
consent to oh an 8-year-old can consent
to and people are going
to feel good with all sorts of deviant
disgusting perverted things that should
obviously be legal so if if we're if
we're recognizing this is a major
problem and we're going to move past
that then what do we do what are the
other moral maxims that are going to
come where where how are we going to
recover a moral order that doesn't
tolerate or incentivize this kind of
stuff you you might look back to I don't
know our our 2,000-year history and the
way that morality interacted with our
law when we had a civilization that we
called Christendom it's probably a good
guide the old Christian morality
which which John Adams says John Adams
who wasn't even particularly religious
said had to be the basis of the American
morality he might do that but then
you're going to start limiting things
and proscribing things and outlawing
things that uh in recent years a bunch
of perverts and freaks have said are
natural rights but they're not they're
not that's how it goes speaking of the
sexual
Revolution little nasx you remember
little nasx he is uh best known for
filming a mus video where he uh is being
uh violated by the Devil Himself but
he's kind of enjoying it uh Lil
nasx has been teasing that he's had a
change of heart and he's going to become
a
Christian don't bug your girl is
black me returning to God after the
industry tried to make me
satanic now he's there and it looks kind
of fake doesn't it this reminds me the
second I saw this video this reminded me
of Snoop Dog who did kind of fool me he
posted on the internet he said I'm
giving up smoke please respect my
privacy in this time
Snoop and he said Snoop Doggy smokes pot
all day long what are you talking about
and then I'm giving up smoke it just
became a a marketing campaign for a a
stove like a smokeless grill that he was
trying to sell and so the minute I saw
that I said okay Lil nasx here this guy
is
I don't buy it it can happen I think it
happened with Kanye I think Kanye
actually had a sincere moment of
repentance when he made that album
Jesus's King and he banned people who
were working on the album from
fornicating and all and then you know
unfortunately he had some public
backsliding as has happened to a lot of
people um but I didn't think that's what
was going on with little NX I thought it
was kind of fake you know we
we God can do anything and turn any
heart but I I didn't really see it here
and so anyway now he's released this
album and it is exactly as Blasphemous
as you might imagine we'll get to that
in one second first though my favorite
comment yesterday is from the slow old
man who says I watched VI and Candace on
Tim pool's show would love to see VI as
Trump's VP and they asked that on pool's
show yeah VI is really
talented I there are people who want to
just write V out of this race and say oh
you know he's a sideshow he didn't make
it to the CNN debate before Iowa so he's
totally out I don't think so actually
he's still polling at a higher rate than
the vast majority of candidates who have
been in this race he is a little bit
outside the box so people are trying to
make him into the I don't know Andrew
Yang or or uh some kind of eccentric
figure in this race
but he's much more intelligent than
basically anyone who's run for president
in decades and he's extremely wealthy
he's worth hundreds of millions of
dollars and I don't think people can
just push F to the side quite like that
ideologically or financially or
politically I just don't think that's
really going to happen Okay little NSX
is
making a big PR stunt and I guess we're
all falling for it he says he's going to
become a Christian take it
[Applause]
[Music]
away with 30 B bust down wrist that's my
bus down 30 in walk up in the club poing
like it was double me let him slide yeah
wasn't yeah tell him come outside baby
we a trying to
[Music]
hide so you've got this dueling battle
between Heaven and Hell he's in both
places and he's playing a basketball
game and the angel Beats the
devil but then he goes into a little
cheerleader
thing is anybody with the I know which
way that we going H This way everything
then he He makes himself into Christ but
he does it upside down which is a
satanic symbol of a a cross upside down
is not satanic but a crucifix upside
down is a satanic
symbol and they're on the
flood for in Christ his new creation the
old has passed away behold the new has
come 2 Corinthians 5:17 yeah true okay
that's not the whole video my producers
spared me having to watch the whole
thing two takeaways which are two things
that we've been talking about actually
all show that's the first time I'm
seeing that music video One
is weird sex stuff is not just frivolous
and silly it it's really bad I'm not
saying it's the worst kind of sin but
it's really bad and it leads one to much
worse sins when we read about ancient
Pagan Cults or when we read about the
Israelites in the desert turning away
from God and worshiping uh golden
calf I don't know what kind of image
people usually form in their minds I but
I think it's a kind of benign image and
it's that's not that when ancient Pagan
Cults would engage in their rituals when
the Israelites in the desert started
worshiping a golden calf they weren't
just sort of standing there and kneeling
down and bowing they were doing lots of
weird sex stuff and and this music video
opens up little nasx is in heaven and he
looks like an angel but he's got this
this sex collar around his neck which is
which is significant because what he's
saying is I'm I'm basically a slave to
sex right that's the collar that is
around my neck and then you quickly
realize that this this angel of Light is
a demon and and this vision of Heaven is
really a rather hellish Vision that's
the first thing it's not just fun in
games if it feels good do
it if it feels good and you have been
well formed and well educated and
brought up and your desires have been
cultivated in a healthy way then feeling
good can be a good thing and that can
lead you toward more good things and a
flourishing life but if you've grown up
in a corrupted way if you have been
traumatized if you've been Mal educated
if if very nasty desires have been
cultivated in you and vices have been
cultivated and habits have been left
neglected then if it feels good is
usually a signal that you should not do
that thing because you you because we're
creatures of habit and so if you
cultivated very bad habits then then the
things that feel good are going to be
really bad for you and if you've
cultivated good habits the things that
feel good are going to be good for you
this is what Aristotle talks about the
nicoman ethics there four kinds of
people in this world the ones who do bad
things and love doing bad things the
ones who want to do good things but they
do bad things they're incontinent the
ones who want to do bad things but they
basically manage to avoid doing bad
things but it's still very hard for them
those are the people who are who are
continent and then there are The
Virtuous people who who want to do good
things and actually succeed at doing
good things and we should strive for the
the latter but in this day and age
especially with the society we live in
it's virtually impossible that's the
first thing that strikes me about that
video the second thing that strikes me
about that music video is
that all this bad
stuff is just an attack on good stuff
all false religion is just a parody
of of the True
Religion it's it's a perversion or an
inversion or an outright denial of the
True Religion what is the satanic
worship service it's called the black
mass and it's just an inversion of it's
a mockery of the true mass of the
Catholic mass this music video which is
which is Blasphemous and
sacriligious just like his last one
where he's getting strued by the devil
what is it is it is it something of his
own creation is this the new little nasx
religion no it's just a mockery of True
Religion Christianity so many ideologies
are just mockeries of True Religion
communism is a mockery of the true
religion that that changes the nature of
freedom and slavery and and oppression
and and
Redemption and it perverts them into a
very materialist kind of way liberalism
is a mockery of Christianity that
substitutes man for God but it's it has
the same language it has the same
trappings it has the same behavior the
thing that unites all of those false
ideologies is the just parodies of the
real thing speaking of the
occult slightly and speaking of
liberalism spreading this is the
funniest story that I have seen quite a
while um Dei is coming to Skull and
Bones Dei diversity equity and inclusion
is coming to Skull and Bones which is
Skull and Bones is the most elite of the
secret societies at Yale and there are a
number of them and Yale is one of the
most elite you know in the old days blue
blooded kind of schools in the country
and but apparently now inside the tomb
of Skull and Bones which is where the
the society meets they have all these
portraits of old white men and they're
taking down the portraits because they
don't like the white men
if if even skull and bones is giving way
to wokeness it's over folks and I think
a lot of people are surprised by this I
think a lot of people believe that you
know there's a shadowy elite who are in
charge and then they foed all this
craziness on the rest of us all this
confusion the Dei and the ESG and the
wokeness and the this is but they
understand they're they've still got
their act together and they're just
using all this stuff to control
us the reality I think is even scarier
which
is there is no adult in the
room rather than liberalism just being a
weapon that is wielded by the shadowy
elite to control all of us liberal ism
is more like an acid that just pours
over everything and corrodes everything
including the shadowy elite including
the shadowy elite who are now having
their portraits taken off the walls okay
including the shadowy elite who become
the victims of their own ideology it's
comforting in that it means that there's
very likely not just one one man you
know clab or someone you know just like
with a big cauldron but um but it's
scary and that it means things can spin
out of control quickly as is happening
right now we're on the brink of World
War III the breaking news last night was
that the United States and the UK are
bombing
Yemen
now what does this mean why are we
bombing Yemen why are we getting
involved in another war in another
country in the Middle
East in principle the reason we're doing
it I think is totally
justifiable because we're not going in
and bombing Yemen just to go fight a war
for Israel right that would not be a
justifiable reason to go do it at least
in my opinion we're not going in and
bombing Yemen to create a thriving
madonian democracy in Yemen I don't
think that would be a justifiable reason
the re reason that the US is bombing
Yemen is because these houti terrorists
in Yemen are blocking up the
international shipping lanes and so
there they the these are very important
shipping lanes they they could be
shutting down or or drastically impeding
world trade and if you're the global
hedgemon that is a big issue that
becomes a national security issue that
that probably justifies the use of a
certain kind of force as long as you're
just flying in and dropping bombs and
getting out of there and you're not you
know putting boots on the ground to
build a new Republic in Yemen um so in
principle I actually think it's not the
worst use of military power the reason
I'm really skeptical of this why I'm
just broadly opposed to this particular
bombing campaign in Yemen is
because the people in charge are almost
certainly going to screw it up and lead
to World War II
so it's not a it's not a problem in
principle I have no problem with using
military force in principle especially
to secure global Shipping you know if if
if if we just let things spiral out of
control and then the shipping breaks
down and then there's a regional war and
then there's a World War okay I have no
problem trying to pinpoint a uh a remedy
to that quickly especially if it's not
going to cost American lives I not not
only not cost American lives not even
really risk American lives the issue
here
is our secretary of defense just
disappeared for three days didn't even
tell the president you probably haven't
even heard of this story our secretary
of defense had an operation to undergo
uh for his prostate he goes in there are
complications he ends up in the hospital
for three days the president the
National Security Council never even
heard about
this until the guy had already been out
for a considerable amount of time that's
not good do you trust Joe Biden to to to
manage a military operation that won't
lead to World War II I don't trust him
at all I don't trust Joe Biden to order
lunch
things can spiral out of control very
very quickly and the irony of course is
we were told that Joe Biden had to
become president because now the adults
are back in charge it's a return to
normality you're right war in the Middle
East and World War breaking out broadly
that is a return to normality that's not
the kind of normality that I want it's a
new year but leftwing companies are
still up to their old tricks ladies help
your fellas wash out the woke once and
for all with Jeremy's razer's new line
of men's Staples not actual Staples for
like a stapler but products he's going
to love the tea tree and argon oil
infused shampoo the conditioner
exfoliating charcoal body wash or if
he's a soap traditionalist who prefers
something to hold on to the oatmeal and
citrus soap scrub they smell great
they're all made right here in the USA
by a Men's Grooming company that does
not hate men shop the new Jeremy's hairf
face and body wash collection kick woke
out of the bathroom when you visit the
store do it through my URL so I get the
referral bragging rights go to
dailywire.com /ns K wle treat your man
to some great Jeremy's razor products
today that is dailywire.com don't go to
dailywire.com Ben then Ben gets the
credit you got to go to dailywire.com
finally finally we've arrived at my
favorite time of the week when I get to
hear from you in the mailbag the mailbag
is sponsored by P talk go to P talk.com
klees today to save an additional 50% on
your first
month take it away hey Mike so about
this intro on your show
you recently had a discussion with Matt
Walsh where he was representing the
people that don't like it because it's
quote unquote kind of gay uhhuh um so
I'm one of those people that don't like
it but I don't think it's kind of gay I
don't think that's the reason it's a
questionable intro I think the reason
it's a questionable intro is because you
are obviously not a little bit on the
Metro side because that's just a joke
that's obviously just a joke that you
say all the time and and so you're very
uncomfortable in the intro it seems to
me it's it seems kind of contri you're
really stiff when you're dancing it
doesn't seem like you know how to dance
which is evidence to me that you're not
really that effeminate so I don't think
anyone would blame you if you did a
re-shoot but that's just me what do I
know
thanks I don't know how to feel about
your
comment because you're saying Michael
you're not a feminite you're you're
actually masculine and that's why you're
a terrible dancer I don't think I'm a
terrible am I a terrible dancer that
took a couple dance classes you know
back in my youth I don't so but if I say
I'm a good dancer then you're saying I'm
a little uh you know
metoo but you say I'm not like that so I
don't huh would I rather be masculine or
a good
danc I don't know next question hey
Michael you've talked a little bit about
Italian cuisine on your show and my
question to you is if you were on death
row what would you choose to be your
last meal it can be as long and
elaborate as you would like
thanks I would choose sweet little
Alisa's
lasagna no question fresh lasagna I know
I probably couldn't couldn't order it on
death row I guess if I asked a lais Rel
Be Ma you ruined my life you're a serial
killer I don't it's really bad but I
will make you your the son you make I
will do that that final final wish that
you have and it it is fresh pasta
obviously you roll it out with the
double zero flour and everything you
know and then but but the key to this
lasagna is it's not a regular lasagna
it's a beef and pork in the bolog sauce
nice little carrot in there too and you
know just a nice little bolog and then
bashal and then obviously the parmesan
and and stacked up very nicely that
would that would be my last meal no no
question next one hi Michael Justin here
I woke I wrote in about uh a little bit
over a month ago I was a guy
who's got some uh interesting feelings
for for his uh best friend but this
isn't about that um recently I've been
uh partially because of you thinking
about converting to Catholicism however
I have a lot of questions um I've
already started for a little bit over a
week now praying the Rosary every day
and I do feel it helps me it makes me
feel like a lot lighter throughout the
day um but I don't know like where to
start because it's like if it was I was
born and raised uh in like Baptist
churches and stuff like that my
grandfather's Deacon um his
church uh and I would say that my
grandmother is uh the second coming of
Mother Teresa but U just minus the
Catholicism um but uh I really don't
know where to start like with Protestant
churches you can kind of just start
going just for just to go uh I don't
know if that's how Catholics work and
there's just a lot I don't know um so if
anything you could help with my
conversion and start going to um
Catholic churches would help thanks love
the show bye yeah that's great that's
great news yeah just go you can just go
go to a mass um if you go to a
traditional Latin Mass which is what I
tend to do uh you'll you'll want to get
a missile so you can either look it up
online just Latin Mass missile or Latin
mass propers and that'll pull up the
translation because presumably you don't
speak fluent Latin or you can order one
online just go to Amazon Latin Mass
missile 1962 it'll come up and then you
can see the translation I think that's
really beautiful if there's not one in
your area you want to kind of dip your
toe in a little bit first um in a a more
maybe accessible Mass yeah just go to
any Mass uh I would not receive the
Eucharist you know I wouldn't go up for
the Holy Communion if if you're not in a
state of grace and you haven't converted
and you haven't had a confession you
know but it's okay just you just stay in
the Pew and pray during that um and uh
but then yeah just go and then talk to
the priest afterward that's not so scary
there's a lot of smells and bells which
can be a little intimidating but no they
they're very nice people it's okay great
news next
one now I love Trump no I love the tax
cuts I love the secure borders I love no
new Wars I love the judicial
appointments and I even love his tweets
I love Trump so much that I voted for
him in two generals and even in two
primaries that's right I voted for him
in March 2020 when he was running un
opposed so if I could snap my fingers
and make him president for four more
years I would do it Heck if I could get
24 more years of President Trump I would
be a happy
but I voting for Vi kwami in the primary
because I am worried about whether Trump
can win yes I know he has a support of
most Republicans and I know that he
beats Biden in most head matchups even
when you consider the swing States
individually but I have a fear that
keeps me up at night and that fear is
one Fanny Willis I'm afraid that in
September when Trump is our nominee and
we have too much momentum to choose
another district attorney Willis is
going to throw Trump in a prison
jumpsuit and he will lose the support of
the most crucial voting demographic
Suburban white women I worry that they
will think a convict is a bad example
for their non-binary sons and that they
would rather have four more years of
crime inflation Mass illegal immigration
and flirtation with nuclear war my
question is are my fears based in
reality or do they present no obstacle
to voting for Donald Trump the founder
of our Feast of CFE thank you as always
for bringing the wisdom of 1390 to
2024 marvelous question as always Arun I
don't want to discourage you from voting
for v i he's a friend of mine and I
really like the guy and I think he's had
a good candidacy so I'm not I'm not
discouraging you from doing that at all
if you want an argument as to why um
Trump's indictments are not uh a reason
to boot him off the ballot but one is
you know if if we establish that
precedent then we're just letting the
Democrats choose our nominee to me the
fact that they want to send him to St
Helena so badly is actually a mark in
his favor makes me think that they
really are afraid of him that if he does
make it to the general that that he
really could win which I think is born
out in the polls though who knows you
know who knows there could be
Shenanigans and the polls are are not
all that
reliable uh I just also think whoever
the nominee is they're going to throw
everything at him so right now for
instance Nikki Haley says that she beats
Biden by 17 points and maybe she does do
better against Biden than Trump does I
I'm a little skeptical but maybe she
does uh but she ain't going to beat him
by 17 points I promise you that it's cu
the Democrats haven't attacked her yet
but the minute they start attacking her
and they're not just going to attack her
with TV ads I mean we're now in the
litigious phase of American democracy so
they're probably going to accuse her of
you know aeta or of you know pillaging a
town or of you know High crimes and
misdemeanors before she ever gets into
office um the same thing they'll
contrive some scandal with one of his
companies or something I don't know
they'll find
something and and and when I say they
find something I mean they probably
won't actually find anything they'll
just make it up and and and use it
against him so I'm past that I I I tend
to
believe that most Americans including a
lot of Democrats think that the
indictments against Trump are wrong that
it's a political persecution even if he
is convicted uh what the Democrats
believe is that once the evidence is
presented and he's actually wearing an
orange jumpsuit that is what's going to
Rally Americans to say no this is too
much uh we can't vote for this guy I
kind of think it's the opposite though I
think that the sight of an American
president and and the most popular
candidate in the presidential race right
now in an orange jumpsuit is going to so
horrify Americans as to the Banana
Republic that we've descended into that
it will help his numbers that's that's
my guess who knows I mean we'll probably
find out but that's my guess question
from
burgard Michael simple economic lesson
you make the cigars we buy and smoke the
cigars no one gets hurt when can we
expect you to hold up your end of this
deal sir delay too long and you could go
down in history is the cause of the
Mayflower Insurrection I know I I know
man I want to say I did warn about this
I didn't think we'd sell out four months
supply of Mayflower cigars in 24
hours I thought it was maybe possible
but I didn't I I'm not saying I would
have bet on that
however I said once that happened I said
look we're going to get a little bit
more stock in who knows what 10,000 cig
20,000 cigars not a lot of cigars and I
mean by industry standards that is a lot
of cigars but I knew we were selling a
lot I said if you want them get them now
log in they're going to be gone in an
hour and then because this is an aged
product that I refuse to rush I I said
it could be months so I'm meeting with
our production guy and our distribution
guy some of the biggest guys in the
cigar industry I'm meeting with them I
think next week and we're going to sort
everything out but I'll tell I don't
want to to give you bad
expectations it's not going to be next
week it's not going to be two weeks from
now it's not going to be a month from
now even I'm I'm confident that by
sometime in
March we will get more cigars to you but
that's a long way away that could be six
weeks to 10 weeks away from Leland hey
Michael do you think it's of any concern
if Epstein is still alive I just saw
some footage of him still doing
maintenance on the island and then
hiding and driving away who shows a
funeral or wake of someone who is
deceased with a different nose on top of
it on national TV if you have nothing to
hide huh well I I don't think Epstein
did maintenance on his Island even when
he was alive so I and I I saw the
pictures they said this isn't really
Epstein because his face looks a little
different I'm somewhat skeptical of that
I don't know I mean the guy was
obviously connected to intelligence in
some way and we know that his business
partner and Paramore gain Maxwell we
know her father was mobbed up certainly
with Israeli intelligence and British
intelligence and maybe Russian
intelligence so I don't know could they
the whole thing is crazy the the fact
that all the cameras went out and all
the guards fell asleep and he happened
to be allowed to kill himself no one
really believes that uh so is it so
insane to say maybe he's still alive no
I guess it's possible I wouldn't put
money on it
though seemed much more likely that he
was killed through
um more elaborate circumstances than
we've led to believe than to think that
he's still maybe he is I just don't know
what I don't know what purpose he would
serve if he were still alive now it'd be
a huge liability for whoever snuck him
out so probably more likely he was
killed one way or another okay it's fake
headline Friday baby I need your help to
pick out the fake headline the rest of
the show continues now you don't want to
miss it become a member use code NOS
kwes a check out for 2 months free on
all annual
plans
[Music]
yeah